hey what's up folks it's a eric tay here
joined by josh aw thanks for stopping by
with me Josh I run a force here the
fourth iteration the last one was kind
of like not so great but you know this
time around like you said it we were
talking earlier maybe this is the time
to get back into it yeah i mean if
you've been getting screwed by orangey
over and over and destiny and banner
gives you the opportunity to really earn
something so you can get level 32 gloves
you can get a nice hand cannon and you
can roll it over and over and get
optimum stats so it's pretty cool just a
few fun facts to remember if you did do
our environment in the past you know
make sure you have your emblem your
shader and your class are more on
because each of those are you know ten
percent buff to experience in terms of
iron banner and then make sure you get
your your tempering buff gonna give
that's going to exponentially grow
through the week you are even saying
that you might want to strategize and do
it sunday monday the last couple days
cuz it's like at the highest peak i
forget how high i got to one hundred
fifty percent of ink and then in America
MLK days monday so a lot of people might
have the day off that's a good day to
grind yeah alright so we're gonna buy
the buff another cool thing that Saladin
has that he's had previously but I guess
I want to talk about it a little bit
more today is uh you can reforge your
weapon and it's only an iron banner
though unfortunately but I think it's
kind of a unique property and it's
interesting because you know obviously
it's in the game but only in this
specific case I kind of wish you could
do this on any gun maybe maybe not
exotics maybe not raid stuff because
that's already very specific with just
other legendaries vanguard crucible but
yeah so I just reforged it and so now
the stats are difference right so like I
have you know this performance bonus
this has quick-draw perfect balance I
got I got explosive rounds which is
something a lot of us like and I guess
final round yeah pretty pretty decent
and like so yeah this next run you can
get up to level 5 by this gun and it'll
go up to 3 31 attack
you can do this over and over until you
get the right version for you so I mean
it's like you're saying they've got the
technology to put this in the game it'd
be great if maybe with the vendors or
something you could do this because like
for Christmas or the holidays everyone
got that gift that legendary and I got a
really good role online I got a badger
scout rifle with explosive rounds and
Firefly but you got one that instantly
got sharted yeah i mean like that was
definitely a random case in terms like I
mean that that's the only way your
weapons gonna roll right it's gonna be
random you don't know what the game's
going to generate for you so you can't
control it right and the Vanguard
crucible sell a kind of specific set of
like oh there's Firefly but there's no
explosive rounds right so you get the
kind of better version of the Badger
because you got lucky yeah and I don't
mind that necessarily but I would like a
way to kind of be like I want the same
you know badger that that you have
because that's kind of like a bait
bringer but a scout rifle version and
it's 331 so that's kind of something you
can do maybe with the two more / or some
some of the other weapons that you can
get from iron banner I mean the most
frustrating part of destiny has to be
the fact that it realized so much on
getting random drops and you can't
control it like sure sometimes you'll
find a legendary Engram or you'll get
something in a nightfall and that's the
only time you're gonna get these random
legendaries with these stats so iron
banner in this situation is a perfect
example of how you could earn a better
weapon to really optimize your gear yeah
I mean I definitely agree you know I
think it would add a lot to the end game
of this it's like that min max thing
maybe it's for hardcore players maybe
it's just for casual hardcore players
but for me it would add a lot of
gameplay time maybe even just a few
hours or whatever through the week just
because you'll have to farm something
right to spend it was two motes there
for iron banner but who knows they could
make any cost maybe they make a
commendation because now I have I'm
building them up and they're useless
yeah I got nothing to buy with those you
don't want those weapons they just
aren't they aren't optimum and you can't
like do anything about it so what's the
point of all those commendations that
would be that that's actually really
interesting idea as a way to
well the reforging aspect of the game is
very similar to like Diablo which I was
talking about earlier and they added
that in Reaper of souls and it was
actually a game changer because it
turned all these legendaries that you
got that were like oh these aren't that
great because they don't have this stat
or I got a bad role or something right
but then when they brought in the
Enchantress you were able to reroll like
one of those stats almost similar to how
the iron banner is right so you can roll
it to optimize that how you want to play
or do a stat that you want and that made
the game so much more fun and I feel
like it could add so much to this end
game 2 but yeah hopefully they'll add
reforging maybe into the game at some
point maybe even transmog that would be
cool or barber shop or something please
i want to get that makeup of my face
I've got the worst thanks Rob handlery
but anyways thanks Josh bruh coming in
and chatting with me about iron banner
and stay tuned to gamespot com for more
destiny coverage
you